>>Alex Komoroske: Let's get started.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Let's get started.
So what the heck of Web components?
>>Alex Komoroske: So When you guys saw that
word component, you probably thought what
is that?
Well, I submit that each and every one of
you know what a component is because
you use them today.
You use them in lots of different cases.
So the first case is in embedded
widgets.
So here if you have a Google+ button inside
your site or a like button or something
like that --
>> Dimitri Glazkov: Or a Twitter button.
>>Alex Komoroske: This is a third-party bit
of code that's running within your site.
It's
something where you have trust issues, right?
They don't want to allow you to mess with
all of their stuff or (indiscernible) privileged
APIs, and they also don't want you to style
their stuff.
So they talk a lot about discipline.
Like, "Thou shalt not use anything under -- sell
anything under my little ID" and stuff like
that.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Right, and of course we
as user of those widgets go, "Eh, it's more
like an etiquette."
Try not to do that stuff and we'll mess with
that the way we want to
to make it look nice.
>>Alex Komoroske: And so in fact, what everybody
does, they give up on these iframes, but that's
not really ideal.
So another use case is when you are writing
your own app, and say you want a tabstrip,
well, you shouldn't have to create a tabstrip
because there are thousands of them that other
people have created; you just want to use
those.
So you just want to grab in a widget or a
component that someone else has written, and
put it inside of your app.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: And there are entire libraries
written nowadays, and some of them are quite
complete, libraries, and widgets and all of
the different UI elements that you might want
to put together.
And of course, unfortunately, the problem
there is that all of these libraries espouse
their own strategy on how to execute the UI
widget composition and how those things come
together.
And so like one of the top stock overflow
questions would be how do I use the widget
from Framework Foo in Framework R, right?
>>Alex Komoroske: Unfortunately, they follow
different conventions, so often the answer
is you use a lot of duct tape, a lot of script,
jam them together as best you can.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Don't touch those parts.
>>Alex Komoroske: And don't do this, whatever
you do.
So the final one is custom-built widgets.
Are you hungry?
So bear with me for a second.
You are all familiar with spaghetti code,
right?
Where you have all of these crazy stuff to
do, really hacky.
When you are writing
your own apps, you want to have this better
fit of encapsulation, right?
Because that's
how you build more complex things.
But it's hard to do in the above platform,
so the best
that you can kind of get is lasagne.
You've got layers, but they're still kind
of messy,
right?
So even when you are building any kind of
app, you are building these custom elements
for yourself.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: The components is, you
know, one use of that.
>>Alex Komoroske: So let's go dive into our
example we will be talking through today.
We're going to build a poll app and show you
how we built this today.
So here it is.
It's a pretty app.
It's got a cool HTML file logo, it's got a
title, a subtitle, different options.
If you
aren't familiar with them, you can hover over
them to see the information about them.
You
can select them.
I selected things.
You can also see the results.
See what other people
have voted for.
But let's dive into how this stuff actually
works.
So I'm going to open up Web inspector here,
I have got this way zoomed in, which is why
it looks so funky.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: And if you look at this
today, and this is a written -- you know,
this is a pretty cutting edge technology even
by today's standard.
Shout out for David who
wrote this code.
It's using what you would call the modern
principles of Web design, and that is, you
know, you do see your components right away.
You see the poll is one component, which is
a backbone view; and then you see the choices
view, results view, and all of those different
things that are put together into a widget
hierarchy of some sort, right?
Unfortunately, some of the things immediately
start jumping out at you and going what's
going on here?
See those strings there?
Your HTML became just a string, right?
It's not a markup anymore.
It's just the cottage cheese in your Lasagne,
right?
And so at this point you are starting to go
and say, "Well, I'm not really working in
HTML anymore; I'm working in this parallel
world that the framework has designed for
me.
And then what happens is this framework will
do the right thing and project the actual
HTML or DOM tree into the browser for user
to see.
And, of course, when the user clicks
on something, the backward thing happens,
you know.
The framework traverses the events
back to your tree to your object hierarchy
and tells you what happened.
It's not just
the deal that was clicked; it's your poll
that was selected.
Ah-ha, I understand this now.
So if you look at this markup right now, you
actually see
this very clearly.
It's that markup is not necessarily representative
of what the poll
is; it's actually a lot of things in addition
to just what should be a very simple widget
layout, right?
You have poll and you have choices and that's
it.
What else should be
going on here?
But there is actually a lot of markup going
on.
That's because the markup
is essentially a projection.
And even worse, today, if you load this page,
it's just a
DIV in markup.
What happens is the framework then blows up
this DIV using the JavaScript and creates
the actual framework out of it.
So -- you think this is bad?
>>Alex Komoroske: Right.
So I actually have
something that haunts my nightmares, and it
will haunt yours, too, after I show you.
So if you open -- if you go to, say, just
Gmail which we all use, know and love, if
you switch and look at the Web inspector in
here, you inspect some random elements -- what
is going on?
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Oh, my God!
What is this?
This should be a very simple widget tree,
right?
There's like a list of things and then
there's -- oh, my God look at this!
Stairway to hell.
[Laughter]
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Right?
What's going on there?
>>Alex Komoroske: This doesn't make any sense.
And so -- this is in this bizarro.
You know,
I bet a lot of you watching this were saying,
"Oh, well that's just how you do it, right?"
Like, why are you talking about why this is
insane?
This is just how you make it work.
You know what, Dimitri?
I submit that everyone in this room who said
that is insane.
Right?
[Laughter].
>>Alex Komoroske: This is insane, this is
crazy.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: We're insane, yay!
All
right.
But the thing is that -- it is true, we are
doing something to work around the issues
in the browser.
And we're writing a lot of
code.
We're writing frameworks to help us do this
-- these bits of code.
Then with more
code that we write, we have more opportunities
for -- for losing test coverage, for example,
and not knowing exactly what's happening.
And clearly more code you ship over the wire,
the slower your application will go, right?
And the development time suffers, of course.
Unless you stay in the confines of that specific
framework, right?
>>Alex Komoroske: So that's sort of on a low
level why this is bad.
On a high level, this
is bad, too.
Right?
If you looked at this DOM, this isn't very
symmetric at all.
I had to look through it.
I didn't really understand what those things
were doing.
The Gmail example, of course, is way on one
end of the spectrum.
But actually
if we look at our index, Google, we see the
Web is getting less and less semantic as we
go.
There's more DIVs and spans.
It's harder to understand what's going on.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: And more empty DIVs, like
I mentioned before, right?
You try to index
a page, you go there, you say, oh, there's
nothing there, no, no, that's actually an
NPR app but loads all kinds of images.
You have to run script to understand that
it does
that, right?
>>Alex Komoroske: So running script means
that you have to -- to make any kind of complicated
app, you have to run script.
You can't be
a web author; you have to be a Web developer
to make something work today.
Okay.
So I have
one bit of good news.
You guys are all insane, but it's not your
fault.
It's the fault of the platform right now and
that's why you have to do these things.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: That's right.
>>Alex Komoroske: So if you look at this,
the rare thing of it, is the Web platform
has all of these amazing technologies that
do all kinds of really cool stuff.
But there are a few little potholes.
A few little tiny
things that don't work correctly or that are
difficult.
And you run into them.
You're on
this information super highway, everything
is working great, you run into a pothole,
and you say, "Ooop, I can't handle this."
But that's okay.
I have script, I have an escape hatch.
I will do this in JavaScript.
It will be okay.
So
you go a little tiny bit off road.
That's fine, right?
Now you run into another pothole, a deeper
pothole offroad.
This means you're offroad,
right?
And it's a pothole that wouldn't have been
there had you been on the highway, had you
been able to use these normal technologies,
but you're offroad.
That's okay.
You write a little bit more script, you go
a little
bit more offroad.
Things are wrong, right?
Unfortunately, this
leads into a pit of despair, right?
Like the more offroad you go, after a certain
point
you are drawing your own cursor, you've completely
escaped the browser here.
[Laughter].
>>Alex Komoroske: You are sort of building
inside this escape hatch.
JavaScript is an escape hatch.
If the (indiscernible) doesn't
do what you need, you are now building everything
inside of the escape hatch.
That's crazy.
Even if you don't think that you are doing
it, you think you are doing a very good job
of being semantic and all of that stuff, well,
the framework they are using is doing it for
you.
They are going completely offroad to do this
kind of stuff.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Right.
And a lot of this framework becomes so robust.
And in order
to become robust, in order to offer the experience
to you that makes sense, they build entire
rendering engines into the browser, so you
have this turducken of the thing.
The rendering
engine is just a rendering surface, and then
there's another one that's being loaded to
the js file that actually does the stuff for
you.
And so it's pretty sad.
>>Alex Komoroske: So, yeah, we've been talking
all doom and gloom so far.
We're going to
turn the page here, and the good news is that
although we look like normal people, Dimitri
and I actually come to you from the future.
[Laughter]
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Yes.
We did come from the future.
You must know there are multiple versions
of the future, and there is one, for example,
where the alien invasion begins in 15 minutes
and the Web platform essentially becomes irrelevant.
>>Alex Komoroske: But there also good time
lines.
The time line we're from is the one where
there's free beer and there's Web components,
so it's not all bad.
So what we want to do is we want to talk to
you about how Web components solves this problem.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: So the Web components is
this new set of technologies that we looked
at -- we created by looking at those potholes
and decided to fill them naturally as things
that fit inside of the Web platform as a whole.
Rather than building a whole new crazy thing
on the side, which we always have done before,
we decided we're going to fill those holes
naturally into something that feels like just
part of the Web platform.
Just part of the standard things that you
normally do in the
browser.
Not a script and not some crazy invention
that is completely brand new.
And so what we did is we kind of found out
that there's three pieces that are missing
and these pieces are Shadow DOM, the custom
elements, and the templates.
>>Alex Komoroske: So let me walk you through
what each of these ones means in practice.
So again, all of these three things are what
come underneath the umbrella of Web components.
So the first is Shadow DOM.
Shadow DOM is what allows you to encapsulate
stuff in the
DOM to hide away all of that crush that you
need to make it look correct.
Custom elements is what allows you to define
your own tabs.
When the HTML parser runs into
your widget, it can instantiate it immediately
for you.
Finally, templates allows you to define HTML
DOM snippets very easily.
So today you are
doing this in long bits of strings and script,
or you are doing script tags with some -- with
some templates there.
This basically just allows you to define it
directly in your HTML,
have it sort of frozen off to the side, so
you can swap it in when you need it.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: It's kind of neat to decide
that developers are -- really like this master
framework, right.
There's problems with the Web platform, but
no matter what, developers
force will work around them or flow around
those problems.
>>Alex Komoroske: They will find a way.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Exactly.
>>Alex Komoroske: So this is sort of like
the low level what the technologies do, but
what does this actually mean in practice?
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Well, in practice, what
you are really are looking for is something
that allows you to tell -- allows you to tell
the browser exactly what you mean.
This, for example, would be the markup that
you are actually are trying to communicate
to the browser.
I have a poll, I have choices,
and there's things that -- that are essentially
data for my poll, right?
Why should there
be anything else?
Right, right, right?!!
>>> Right!
>>Dimitri Glazkov: All right!
So the three pieces fit very neatly into this
idea.
First
Shadow DOM allows you to take the scaffolding
all of the weird DIVs that are really irrelevant
to the semantic of the markup, and hide them
into the Shadow DOM -- which we will talk
more about later.
Then the custom elements allow you to define
new tags, right?
New tags,
awesome?
X-poll, right?
And specify behavior and assign things on
top of them.
Then, of course, the templates allow you to
stop treating markup as string, which is always
nice.
>>Alex Komoroske: So that's how they help
tactically, but they also, of course, are
really important on the high level.
So if
you have this world, this is all you need
to pass down to the browser to have that rich
poll experience exist, that means that you
don't need this bizarro script.
DOM can be
your only hierarchy.
You don't need to have this parallel bizarro
hierarchy on the side.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: You no longer need to build
your widget hierarchy as just a, you know,
an object tree somewhere off to the side.
The one that projects the DOM is a kabuki
theater of some sort.
>>Alex Komoroske: So DOM can become this lingua
franca of the Web.
It also means that you would have real encapsulation,
so you wouldn't
have to worry about people coming in and messing
with your innards and messing up how your
component works, because they can't because
it would be a barrier.
So it's not just etiquette or discipline.
It's an actual encapsulation barrier.
Also
if DOM is the composition mechanism, it already
composes really nicely.
You can put a span,
DIVs, all kinds of stuff, right?
If you have that as the framework that you
use for composability, that means that you
have compatible composability.
So if you have
a widget from Framework A and Framework B,
they can live together harmoniously without
having to figure out which widgets they have
-- it's just DOM.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Right.
And where that one widget begins and where
one widget ends.
That's
another important thing.
Let's be clear.
Web components is not a set of those widgets.
It's just a platform on which the future frameworks,
you know, the future where we're from?
Can
build those new frameworks.
>>Alex Komoroske: So it's a foundation for
this stuff.
Okay.
So this -- actually, Web components
as you may have guessed, makes all of this
stuff real.
So we're going to show you what
it looks like in practice.
So let me switch.
This is the demo that we showed; it's built
using the best practices of today.
And this is what the -- what the one with
Web components looks like.
Right?
Looks exactly the same.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Yeah.
Right.
So in the future, all applications are going
to look
exactly the same, right?
This is the lesson that we are learning?
Well, actually, no.
What's interesting here, this is actually
a functional application, but instead of all
of these weird spans and DIVs inside of it,
it has a very clear, very concise markup.
This markup is exactly the same as the actual
DOM structure off this document, right?
So whatever you ship over the wire is exactly
the same thing that is represented as DOM.
You don't have to create this thing that the
frameworks -- the rendering decorate where
you just first load the page and then you
go find those things that you want to upgrade
and make them into the right stuff, you don't
have to do that anymore.
All of this happens
magically?
>>Alex Komoroske: Magically, that's actually
a good point.
I was going to ask, clearly we saw all of
the extra stuff that's required
to make this poll demo work.
But it's not here, so what's going on?
All right.
Well,
let's look.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: And kind of the way that
you look at this is in the Web platform, we
never had this opportunity to -- to build
in layering.
Layering is like a cool thing.
It's not -- it's also related to the lasagne
thing.
But all of the frameworks, if you look at
them together, all of the JavaScript frameworks
that are built out today are nothing but attempts
to provide a layering in the browser.
Because what they want to do is they want
to create
an environment in which the users of this
framework don't have to think about the details.
And then the developers of the new widgets,
the builders of the components, the ones who
work inside of the framework, actually have
flexibility and power to, you know, provide
those new services to the -- to the higher
level.
>>Alex Komoroske: By having this built into
the browser, it means that there's no build
step, there's no extra framework you can use,
you might be able to build the users of this
components, which is what the vast majority
of the Web developers will be doing, it's
super simple, you do an import, you use these
tags, it just works, however, if you really
want to understand the magic going on behind
this, you need to go a little bit behind the
scenes, you have to see these more powerful
concepts that are a little bit more confusing
that have a lot more to learn about.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: We have a choice here,
do you guys want to continue or should we
just stop right here, behind the scenes!!??
Yes.
>>Alex Komoroske: Okay.
So we're going to
go behind the scenes.
If at this point you say what the heck is
going on, that's okay,
you can just be a user of these components
and not have to worry about it.
Dimitri, why
don't you take us behind the scenes?
>>Dimitri Glazkov: First we're going to talk
about Shadow DOM.
Believe it or not, Shadow DOM already exists
on the browsers, well and
alive, and the one and good example would
be a video tag.
Let's take a look at this
video tag right here embedded into this presentation,
because, you know, our presentations are actually
HTML as well.
Right?
Okay.
So as you can see you have really neat video
tag right there,
right?
Video/video, everything looks great, but there's
actually more stuff happening.
There's slider there in the time line, and
all these things.
How do browser developers
do this?
Right?
How do they draw those things?
Well, they have a couple of choices: One of
them is build the whole thing from scratch
to build their own, testing right into this
thing, and we're kind of actually lazy and
we didn't do that.
What we did instead is we invented a way where
we could stash away
a DOM tree where we can build those things
out of just normal CSS and DOM, and operate
on them just the normal way, and then we present
it to you as if this is a built-in functionality,
and this DOM tree, we obviously called Shadow
DOM, right?
It's in the shadows.
>>Alex Komoroske: So how can we see what's
going on here?
>>Dimitri Glazkov: So one of the interesting
things is in Chrome browser, today you can
opt in to this experiment and you can say,
well, I want to be able to show Shadow DOM,
and so if you're a load inspector, you will
see that, when you inspect the video, suddenly
there's more stuff inside of it.
It's that
thing called shadow root.
That's that hidden DOM that you can't see.
Let's go inside of
it.
Oh, there's a DIV.
Oh, interesting input type button.
That's actually the play button,
and then the input type or this style, open
that one right there, that will be a type
range.
That's the slider, right?
That's the thing.
So what we did is we really,
really cheated in a pretty big way, right?
We just -- instead of building all this stuff
in C++, you know, and all this stuff, it's
just DOM.
And, in fact, when you play this
video, and you know how the timeline goes
away, that is just a CSS transition, right?
It's nothing special.
>>Alex Komoroske: So what you're saying is
that this stuff, this isn't new, Shadow DOM
has existed in some browsers already.
What
is new is exposing it to web developers.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Right.
So what we did next,
we said, well, wouldn't it be cool if Web
developers could have the same power, and
wouldn't you agree that would be cool?
Would that be cool?
All right.
So that's what Shadow DOM is about.
It's about encapsulation and providing you
with the ability to add these extra chunks
on DOM tree and render them as if they're
part of the bigger rendering.
>>Alex Komoroske: Okay.
This is kind of complicated,
so let's go through this in a little bit more
depth.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: All right.
Sounds good.
So the next slide here that we see, we have
a nice diagram.
As you can see it's peas and radishes, clearly.
So the green notes, the
peas represent the document tree, that's the
actual tree that you see when you go into
the inspector, and that's the one that is
parsed, when the browser parses your markup,
and the pink stuff is the Shadow DOM tree,
so the Shadow DOM allows you to associate
a special subtree with every DOM element,
and then this subtree, you can build and create
DIVs and all kinds of things inside of it,
but then when it's rendered, you actually
see the shadow subtree rendered instead of
the contents of that node, the element that
you associate it with.
>>Alex Komoroske: Okay.
So let me go over
this one more time.
So what we have here on the left, we have
these green nodes, or just
the logical DOM that we're all familiar with,
and then off to the right we have a sort of
parallel DOM hierarchy.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: That's right.
>>Alex Komoroske: And so it's sort of stashed
off to the side.
But if the Shadow DOM is
defined, when we render, what we see, is as
though the pink nodes were underneath the
green nodes.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: That's right.
>> Alex Komoroske: So magically the green
ones are still there.
>> Dimitri Glazkov: Right.
So this is a really, really cool concept right
here, it's a render
time composition.
You don't have to move those nodes around.
They're still there -- if you
walk your, you know, first child, next child
thing, next sibling, there's going to be only
the green tree inside of it, but at render
time, the shadow DOM tree will be placed on
top and rendered as if it's there.
>> Alex Komoroske: I had real stuff in that
-- in that real in the green DOM tree.
I want to show that.
It's kind of weird this is sort
of (indiscernible)
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Right.
Yeah, this use case
is pretty good for a video, but you suddenly
lost that other green peas things that were
hanging off the element, so what do we do
there?
We have this really, really cool concept called
insertion point.
Insertion points are special
elements that you can put into your Shadow
DOM subtree to designate where the children
of the shadow root will poke through, and
so as you can see there, I have two insertion
points and when it's rendering, again at render
time only, those children will shine through
inside of the Shadow DOM tree, so in a way
it allows you to have this way to compose
the Shadow DOM subtree around your documents
node.
>> Alex Komoroske: This is the same thing
that frameworks are doing today, right, because
you have like your markup, then you call this
magic decorate method on it, then it swaps
your DOM directly into the place it needs
to be to render.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: That's right.
>>Alex Komoroske: This leaves it in the same
place as before so you can still interact
with it like you did before.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: The cool thing here, exactly
right, is that this is entirely render time,
so you don't have to touch the DOM, in fact
the DOM stays exactly the same.
What happens
is this happens only at render time, so only
when this stuff shows up on the page is things
appear in the right spot.
>>Alex Komoroske: Okay.
So this is all very
abstract.
Let's go through a more concrete example.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Sure.
For example, the <x-choice> element that we
have just seen
in the markup example here is implemented
using Shadow DOM, so you can see there it's
a very simple subtree.
The Shadow DOM subtree has a DIV in it and
has a little mask which
stands for the little icon there, but then
you have this really interesting thing called
content.
Content is a name of the insertion point;
it's the HTML element which represents
the insertion point.
And then you see it has a select attribute
in a value that looks very
similar to something.
What does it look like?
People from the audience?
Is that --
>>Alex Komoroske: CSS?
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Right, so that's what you
use.
You use CSS selectors to say which items
will show through in my insertion point?
And so what we say here is the H3, first of
type, which is the first H3 we find as child,
is going to show up right here instead of
this thing when rendering, and then we have
a little aside item for our tool tip, and
then we say, eh, everything else, universal
selector goes inside there.
>>Alex Komoroske: So what we're doing basically
is we're using CSS to decide which elements
to sort of funnel and tele-port where when
we render.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: That's right.
>>Alex Komoroske: Okay.
So what we're actually
kind of doing here too is we're almost defining
a declarative API.
We say if you provide some
H3s, the first ones, what we'll use as the
actual name for the thing and later ones we'll
just establish another --
>>Dimitri Glazkov: So you have this not only
mechanism to stash things away into the subtree,
you also have a mechanism to now declaratively
project some of the items.
You don't have to write a bit of script to
do this.
This
is all built in.
This is standard stuff.
Awesome?
Awesome.
All right.
Okay.
And so the next thing is we need to take these
Shadow DOM subtrees and build them into something
useful, and that's where custom elements come
in.
Custom elements allow you to define a
new element, and for that purpose we have
the new HTML element -- that's a good name
for it -- which allows you to specify and
say, well, there's my element, <x-choice>,
and inside of it, the template.
Remember the template?
That's where my Shadow DOM subtree
instance is.
Every time I create a new <x-choice>, that
will be stamped out and create a new
instance of the Shadow DOM subtree.
And then you can run script inside of it to
do lots
of cool things.
For example, you can declare an imperative
API, and say, well, the <x-choice>
method needs extra methods -- or <x-choice>
object needs extra methods or properties on
it, and you can do this.
And also you can define things like life cycle
hooks, like
I want to run some scripts, register events
every time a new instance is created, right?
That's useful stuff.
>>Alex Komoroske: So that's how you define
it as a component author.
For component users all you have to do, you
include this link
to the components and point to the document
where this thing is defined, and then you
can just use it like any other built-in tag
in your page.
And also, so you talked about
those imperative APIs we defined here, was
selected on this thing.
If I go through and
grab this element out of the DOM using various
lectures, say, I can just call that method
directly on that object, the DOM object.
The DOM object is the object.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Right.
And there's no faking there, right?
There's no need to create separate
objects or view or things, your DOM objects
are the actual things that you operate on.
When you query the standard DOM APIs, use
them, whatever comes back to you is going
to be those things that you define.
>>Alex Komoroske: You don't have to know the
convention of the framework, how we stash
things and how DOM are related.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: And also the link rail,
the new rail components, gives you the opportunity
to create the packaging mechanism to build
packaging right into the browser.
You don't
have to have a build script that then compiles
all this thing into one gob of code.
You don't
have to have five script tags loaded into
your page.
One link rail, you can load other
link rails if you want, you will have more
components that you want to reuse, and that's
all it takes.
So it's packaging.
It's reuse.
And also the ability to have one DOM hierarchy
instead of multiple tree objects.
>>Alex Komoroske: So one of the problems we
have today on the Web platform is styles sort
of naturally go all over the place.
And so
when you're designing a style for your component,
it might go and mess up somebody else inadvertently.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: That is a very common problem,
especially if your object tree is pretty complex.
At some point you really start losing sight
of where -- which selector, and you know,
how many of you guys have committed the Cardinal
sin of pound important?
Okay.
Be honest here
now.
And so in Shadow DOM, there is some really
cool stuff here.
In Shadow DOM the styles
are implicitly or explicitly scoped inside
of the Shadow DOM subtree.
So even if you
put a universal selector inside of the Shadow
DOM subtree, it will only apply instead of
inside of the Shadow DOM subtree.
So it will not go and bleed out into a document.
Similarly,
styles that you apply in the document will
not bleed into your Shadow DOM subtree.
So
you have a very nice style separation boundary
which really works extremely well for widget
case scenarios where you want to have the
boundaries defined and you don't want people
to stomp on your styles, and you want to keep
some sort of sanity inside of your application.
>>Alex Komoroske: Okay.
So that is sort of behind the scenes.
Thank you for that, Dimitri.
I actually just got a call from a designer,
he's watching on the live stream, and he says
that we shouldn't have used accordion, we
should have used a tab strip in our demo.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: I actually agree with the
designer, accordions are kind of weird anyway,
right, a cross between a piano and a harmonica,
really?
Oh, you're talking about a widget.
I'm sorry.
Okay, yes.
So that is actually really easy,
because we're using just markup, we're just
swapping tags, so the idea of swapping out
components now becomes just changing your
markup, right?
So now we have to just include
in your component and then change X accordion
to be X tabs, and it's, you know, it's -- we'll
just see what happens, right?
>>Alex Komoroske: Okay.
So you say I have
to include the new component, which I actually
already did when you were talking, and I needed
to change X-accordion to X-tabs, is that right?
Save that, switch back to the demo and just
refresh.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: And now we have tabs.
Applause,
please.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>>Dimitri Glazkov: No wing suit drop, no wing
suits, but at least, you know, some cool tricks,
right, at some point.
All right.
So this looks really, really awesome and I'm
already kind
of enamored with this.
I don't know about you guys.
But I really want this poll on my
website now.
>>Alex Komoroske: On your site.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: On my site.
>>Alex Komoroske: just so guys know, I'll
show you what Dimitri's website looks like.
It's beautiful.
It's really special.
It's
awesome.
So, no offense, Dimitri.
I definitely hear that you want to have this
poll on your
site.
I'm a little bit concerned that you might
mark with it a bit, but that's okay.
I'm going to package this up for you so that
you can include it on your site without you
worrying about how you're going to set this
up.
First of all, I don't want you to be able
to change the text for the choices, that way
you could stack the deck.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: I could add my own choices,
right?
CSS 3.
Why not CSS 4 or 7?
>>Alex Komoroske: So what I'm going to do
actually is I'm going to create a new element
called awesome poll, obviously.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Has to be awesome, awesome
site, right.
>>Alex Komoroske: And then to hide it from
people who are vetting it, I'm going to take
and put in my Shadow DOM one of those polls
so you can't see it.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Okay.
>>Alex Komoroske: Then what I'll do is I'll
allow yourself to define sort of where this
configuration is, and I'll then create all
the stuff inside the X poll in my own little
area.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Have you guys seen inception?
And if you haven't, please leave the room
now.
It's like we have to go one level deeper,
right?
Shadow DOM inside of the Shadow DOM.
You know, seriously cool stuff.
>>Alex Komoroske: Okay.
So what we'll do, so then you can just put
that right in your
page and you will have the poll right there.
Awesome.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Wow, this is -- well...
>>Alex Komoroske: What?
>>Dimitri Glazkov: It kind of looks not like
my site actually.
The place my vote clearly
doesn't have enough exclamation points.
I don't know.
I kind of want to customize it
a little.
>>Alex Komoroske: Okay.
Okay.
So you're right.
This is actually technically just as good
as an iframe basically.
Doesn't give you any
way to customize it.
So you have such an interesting vocabulary
and way of speaking.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: I do.
I'm a very colorful person.
>>Alex Komoroske: I don't want you to have
control over everything, but I guess -- I
guess subtitle and the button will allow you
to override.
So I'm going to define in my
poll, I'm going to allow you to have a declarative
API, allow you to define your own aside for
that subtitle and your own label text.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: That sounds good.
>>Alex Komoroske: What we'll do is we'll switch
back to your site.
Right here.
I already wrote
in here where you had this customization,
save that, switch back to my demo, refresh,
and vote for CSS 3 because it's awesome, and
vote now.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Now I have plenty of exclamation
points, right, guys?
Think about what just happened.
Just stop for a second.
I have customized a poll without
mucking it up, because Alex is a developer
of this custom component, of this web component,
the awesome poll, only gave me the guardrails
to step into this specific areas, and that's
all.
And the way I do this is by markup.
I don't have to go GS and do some weird muckety
muckety JSON stuff.
Well, you know, the font kind of looks like
a clean and creepy.
I want
something huggable and wonderful.
What could be more wonderful than comic SANS?
It's from
the perfection, right?
So what we're going to do -- I want to say
that I'm not going to do this unless you let
me customize the font.
>>> I admire design aesthetic, I think it's
very unique, but I don't want you to be able
to run all over this stuff and break everything,
so I guess what I'm going to allow you to
do is change a couple of things in here, before
I do that, I'm want to walk you through how
I'm going to do this.
So CSS variables is one new technology, the
spec is nearing completion.
We actually have it implemented in Chrome
behind the flag.
CSS variables --
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Wait, wait, wait, did you
just say CSS variables?
Guys, are you getting
this?
Are you getting the CSS variables?
>>Alex Komoroske: Yeah, it's kind of cool,
right, because today you have to have, define
pound FFF, one, two, three, four, like 8,000
places in you're CSS.
This allows you basically to define it once.
So they're actually really,
really powerful.
You can do all kinds of cool stuff with cascade
and referencing other variables.
We don't need that today.
I really encourage you guys to look more into
CSS variables and
all the crazy, amazing stuff it can do, but
the cool thing about CSS variables is it allows
a very natural place for me to allow you to
override what I want.
So when I'm writing
my poll, I'll use CSS variables very deliberately
in places that I want you to be able to hook
in and change my stuff.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: So these are my styling
hooks.
I can't go anywhere and mess with anything
else.
>>Alex Komoroske: I'm only giving you -- allowing
you to change a few things.
So in this case
I'll allow you to change maybe the font and
also the color that we use as the primary
color.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Colors are important.
>>Alex Komoroske: What you'll do on your sheet
is you'll just style -- direct some styles,
these variables at my poll, and then it will
magically just work.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: I want to see this.
>>Alex Komoroske: I'm going to switch to CSS,
and I'm going to uncomment -- I've already
written --
>>Dimitri Glazkov: You made the right choice.
>>Alex Komoroske: Comic sans, I thought you
would like that.
I'm going to switch back to my -- to your
site.
Refresh.
There you
go --
>>Dimitri Glazkov: This is now awesome.
I
can do this.
[ APPLAUSE ]
But again take a second to think about this.
Now you as the developer of the widget or
a component can give specific instructions
to the browser on what to permit the user
of the component to do.
Isn't that awesome?
Isn't that styling APIs?
Who wants this?
[ Applause ]
>>Alex Komoroske: I want this.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: All right!
>>Alex Komoroske: Cool.
So we've walked you through a couple of examples
of how to use
this stuff and also some of the tactical uses
you can have with this.
And actually is a bigger deal than just that.
The way that I think of that actually -- I'm
actually a little bit dramatic, I guess sometimes,
is the declarative Renaissance.
So way long
time go, you just used HTML, you just wrote
(indiscernible) code straightforward, and
then we started using JavaScript a lot for
a lot of stuff, right?
But now this allows
people to return back to writing things very
declaratively in most cases.
There's a lot
of stuff that allows that to happen.
>>> And like one of the most important things
that I think is -- the ability to actually
talk via an API.
Or tell the browser, specify
to -- to let the user know: These are the
things that you can do and no more.
And no
matter how much you hack about on this or
do whatever this -- whatever, you can't mess
up my stuff.
My stuff is safe.
I gave you these hooks, that's all that you
can do.
You
have CSS variables for the styling API and
you have the components, the Shadow DOM technology,
to allow you to have the markup API.
And then you, of course, can define -- define
the imperative
API on custom elements.
So the Web components give you those three
things.
To essentially
explicitly define APIs on the components now.
Awesome stuff.
>>Alex Komoroske: So another one that's really
cool is we talked about before, if DOM is
your composition mechanism, then components
from different libraries just work together.
This is neat, I'm like oh, cool, you can get
whatever widget you want.
But it also means
that today we have to spend all of this time
recreating tabstrips and calendar controls
and everything in each and every framework.
And, of course, each time you do it, you probably
aren't going to get 100% perfect, but 80%
of the way there.
But if everyone can use
any calendar component, then people will start
using the better one, it will be more of an
incentive to build really, really awesome,
accessible, beautiful, interactive components.
You will see a lot better components as well.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Right.
No longer you have
to pledge allegiance to a specific framework.
That little mini browser that was built inside
of your browser, you can say well, no longer
I am just specifically a backbone man.
I can
just use markup and mix them around, because
this is just markup.
It's a common media.
Just standard stuff is in the DOM, in your
browser.
If you look at this, you can clearly see another
advantage.
For a -- for a company or a team
of people working on the same Web applications,
ability to encapsulate offers tremendous advantages,
right?
Because now you can work on this stuff without
worrying about stepping on each other's
toes, you can have a clean separation, you
can build work flows that actually make sense
and not have this crazy schemes of discipline
built into this.
Making that sure your selectors
have to start with #foo and all of that thing
that you have to do today when you build complex
applications.
>>Alex Komoroske: Cool.
So the other case
is that again most cases are fully declarative.
So these people who don't know script, they
don't have a CS degree, they can still be
really productive.
They can build really cool
stuff with these components.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Right.
And one of the other
things here is because the browser is taking
care of loading and understanding the packaging
obligations, the rendering of the things,
it can go much faster because the browser
ultimately kind of knows more about rendering
than any author or any JavaScript engineer
could do because we have a little more hooks
than standard JavaScript application could.
>>Alex Komoroske: The final one, and this
one is kind of crazy, so bear with me, is
the rise of shared semantics.
So today your semantics might only apply within
your site
because there's no good way to share them.
But if you allow people to define these tags
that are useful to Web developers, it's very
obvious if we are -- for example, we will
see these x-polls, it's very obvious that
people find that useful.
And so this is a
great way for Web developers to experiment
with new components and things.
After a while,
maybe you will see that everyone is using
tabstrips, they are using it in the same basic
way, well, we just roll that into the spec,
roll that into the standard.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Directly into HTML.
>>Alex Komoroske: Directly into the browser.
Why do you have to define your own?
This is a great place for Web developers to
experiment,
show us the way as browser developers, about
what stuff we should be directly baking in.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Right.
And if you look at it from another slightly
different perspective,
is that today there is no path from local
semantics, the semantics of your framework,
to the global semantics, the public semantics
of HTML.
Once you've built that thing imperatively,
there is no existence of the actual tags,
there is no path to the tags.
You can just
study those things, and look at the patterns
and wonder what is the right thing.
But there
is no path.
With the custom tags, you actually start having
this path because these are just
tags.
And now all that you have to do is run a really,
really large query, which Google can do actually,
and figure out which elements are common.
Then you can know precisely which tags are
winning, which tags deserve to become more
public and at some point make it into the
-- into the HTML spec, for example.
>>Alex Komoroske: It's really cool stuff.
Again, Dimitri and I come from the future,
so that's why we can talk about all of this
amazing stuff.
The good news is actually that
the future isn't quite as far away as you
might think.
We aren't from, like, years in
the future; we're from, like, a few months
in the future, basically.
So shadow DOM and CSS variables are both implemented
in Chrome today.
They are behind the 5.
They
aren't released on the Web yet, but if you
really want to you can go on and play with
them.
There are lots of effective polyfills.
Polyfills are basically shims that allow you
to use functionality before it's directly
in the browser.
We'll talk about those in
a second.
And another thing is this is not a Chrome
thing.
This is being done in standards,
we have a lot of other browser vendors are
extremely excited about the number of folks
from those are in the audience today.
We are really working, this is a collaborative
effort,
a concerted effort with everybody to build
this.
So this is something that you can actually
look forward to using relatively soon.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: It's happening, guys, it's
coming, seriously.
>>Alex Komoroske: So what can you guys do
that you are all jazzed up about this stuff?
Well, you can help the future arrive faster.
The one way -- there's lots of links and information
on this slide.
What you should do right now
if you are already a member of the Web components
plus page is follow us.
We have a Google short
link right there for you.
This is where we post interested updates about
the spec, the
implementations, cool examples, blog posts.
It's the one place that you can really learn
about all of this stuff going on.
And right after this we're going to post all
of these
links to that plus page.
If you want to, you can read the introduction
to Web components.
You probably learn that specs are really hard
to read and they often
are, but actually Dimitri has done an amazing
job writing an explainer, that goes through
all of these concepts, in quiet some depth
but in a very readable way.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: I promise there's no comic
sans on that page.
If you are scared.
>>Alex Komoroske: You can also read the CSS
variable spec, understand more how that stuff
works, all of the amazing stuff that you can
do with it.
It's really more powerful than
it looks.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: The other thing is that
there is actually a lot of really cool discussions
happening right now in your present about
the Web components and working out all of
the corner cases, working out the kinks of
how things should work precisely.
I mean we're in the future, all of those things
are solved,
we don't have to worry about them, but you
guys have to worry about it.
Because getting
this stuff done just right and making sure
this does not suck is really, really important.
So, please, if you have any, you know, gumption
for bike shedding, or really, really endless
discussions with no end, please join the standards
list and start listening in, start understanding
what's going on, what's happening.
>>Alex Komoroske: It's also possible to start
building with this stuff today.
Dimitri has written a polyfill for Web components,
all
it requires is Shadow DOM, so you would have
to turn it on in Chrome to play around with
it.
That's a really cool thing that actually makes
the polyfill for this entire thing,
everything that we have shown you today is
how we actually did --
>>Dimitri Glazkov: You know those self driving
cars?
It's like that.
It's like a very, very
early prototype that you can possibly drive.
Bad things may happen, I can't guarantee--
>>Alex Komoroske: Don't use that one for anything
in production today are written by Daniel
Buchner, who I believe is right there from
Mozilla, he's built this really cool library
called x-tags.
X-tags is basically a polyfill for the custom
elements part of what we showed
you today.
The cool thing about that is this actually
works in all major browsers.
It uses a number of very clever hacks to do
it, but you actually
can start building real apps on top of this
today if you want.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Daniel is actually actively
at work building a pretty, pretty solid toolkit
on top of this, the UI widget library that
would potentially power some really, really
cool applications in the future.
>>Alex Komoroske: That's really cool, so check
that out once we post the link to that plus
page.
All right, great!
So that's all that we have for you today,
we wanted to share a little
bit more about Web components, it's a really
exciting thing for the future.
Thanks so much
for coming out.
[ Applause ]
>>Dimitri Glazkov: And -- and in the future
-- the future bus leaves in 10 minutes, but
until then we can answer your questions if
you would like.
>>Alex Komoroske: Come up to one of these
microphones that we've got here in the aisles.
>>> What about events?
>>Alex Komoroske: What about events is the
question we got from the audience.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: The events are actually
also handled by the Shadow DOM specifications,
and there's really neat things that we do
to make sure that the information in the event
never escapes outside of the Shadow DOM subtree,
but the events are heard.
It's called retargeting.
What happens is that if something fires, like,
for example, if you click a play button in
your video element, the event or the click
event propagates out, but it looks like it
came from the video element.
Does that make
sense?
So it's actually a really complex part of
those things, and we fought extremely hard
to make sure that Shadow DOM feels transparent
to the user and it doesn't look like it's
affecting any actual normal operation of the
events.
But the information from the inside
of the Shadow DOM subtree never leaks out
on the outside.
>>Alex Komoroske: We've got a question at
this mic.
>>> So it sounds like a lot of this is helping
you with bringing in dependencies and encapsulating
code.
Have you guys thought much in the spec about
dependency management, you know, I mean,
obviously a lot of Java developers and a lot
of developers in general use Maven for that,
so you don't get dependency explosion with
inside your app.
There's that encapsulated
part but, you know, in a team you want to
try and use consistent dependencies across.
Has that been addressed in the spec at all?
>>Dimitri Glazkov: At this point there is
just early discussions on how this actual
linking of the custom elements, the packaging,
will happen, so this is actually a good time
to start talking and start discussing this
type of thing.
I mean you saw that in the future and you
saw it works but, you know,
later on.
>>> What about like with media queries where
the widget, the component need to adapt based
on certain break points, and usually those
break points are going to be different based
on whatever context of the app they are used
in.
Right.
So one of the interesting things there is
that first of all we made sure that
Shadow DOM actually operates within the confines
of CSS, we are not inventing anything abnormal,
so all of the CSS machinery the way that you
operate on it will just work.
It just feels,
it has the same -- it will feel like it's
just part of the documents.
So you will get
all of the same information about the size
and media queries, things like that.
>>> (Inaudible).
>>> I'm an extension developer in the users
group aficionado, and there's lots of templated
sites out there that don't use that yet, but
that would be great to extend.
And are you thinking about how to integrate
this into
the Chrome extension API so that we can add
components where there are none and change
them?
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Shadow DOM is actually
one of the really, really use cases for extensions,
the ones that modify the page on the fly.
Because what you can do is you can build a
Shadow DOM into an element and the document
doesn't know that it's there.
And so yes, it's a very common use case, yes,
it's coming.
>>> Thank you.
>>> I'm a (indiscernible) developer but I
was thinking could you invent the map API
into the Shadow DOM so it would build a custom
tech for example a store locator and give
that to a customer and say, hey, do this and
--
>>Alex Komoroske: That's a phenomenal use
case, doing exactly that.
In fact, one of the components of x-tag --
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Talk to this guy, he's
already got one.
>>Alex Komoroske: That's an awesome use case
for it.
Yeah.
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Come on, bring it on!
>>Alex Komoroske: Anything else?
>>> What about the SCO, like there's potential
information like the SI tag that would be
less important, would Google bot pick that
up because it's not potentially rendered on
the page?
>>> We don't work on the search team so we
don't know the answer to that question.
We can imagine there's going to be interesting
changes in the way that people --
>>Dimitri Glazkov: It doesn't have to be on
the SI tag, it can be on H1 or poll, if you
want it to.
It's up to you to define it as
the author of the API.
>>Alex Komoroske: If there are any other questions,
Dimitri and I will be hanging around for few
minutes afterwards if you want to ask us any
other questions.
Thanks so much.
[ Applause ]
>>Dimitri Glazkov: Yay!